[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody welcome new Thursday
today Thursday everything's a blur like
I say today we are going to be playing a
way out we have it it technically comes
out tomorrow but the embargo went up
this morning all the reviews went out
and we're gonna be playing through the
first hour hour and a half give or take
yeah we'll see how it goes both have not
played this game yet so it should be
interesting
yes so you we are gonna be giving you
guys our first impressions you're gonna
see two people play through the coop
together make it happen we got empty
empty brains no biases pretty much my
only bias is I did read Oscar day as his
review six out of ten as he gave it a
six out of ten yeah so I'm not gonna try
to let that color my experience though
going in yeah optimistic trying to have
some fun all right you have the stick so
here we're gonna play local okay right
now I have it kind of like this but like
I said things will change it split
screens a lot because you can local
co-op or online co-op yes so I'm just
guessing it's gonna split this way first
prop Corazon de lis but if it doesn't I
have a back-up plan Sam oh boy and we
got this one too so we start with this
one and then we'll see what happens okay
cool I don't know yeah I hear that it
goes between all the difference yeah
splits so all right all right this is
not uh oh oh oh no all right Oh am i
yeah oh I'm in charge sweet who do you
want to be the bearded fellow or okay
can you hit join now there we go
Here I am alright we're doing a new game
I don't know those muttonchops are
pretty sweet
nice Vincent what's your blend after
this I don't know I haven't really
thought about it you haven't thought
about it that must be first for you mr.
over-thinker there's a difference
between overthinking things and being
smart Leo are you implying that I'm not
smart that's five words
surpri Leo be smart in your book but I
do get [ __ ] done Saxon is this argue
with that you gotta ask the OSA what's
up Dennis Dex hey guys welcome we're
just starting here yeah so am I am i Leo
did you say I'm a Leo age 36 that's
close I want to be the 43 year old
bearded gentleman right here we are
so my crime is fraud embezzlement and
murder I'm about to serve 14 years in
prison
rational disciplined reserved after
earning a college degree and financing
and marrying his high school sweetheart
Vincent said at lunch I've been banking
promises of easy money ends up
shattering his whole life when he got
drawn into the world of organized crime
I'm convicted for armed robbery assault
grand theft I served six years out of my
or started six months out of my eight
years well that's like nothing I'm
confident I have a short temper I'm a
joker I was brought up in an orphanage
and turned to crime early in my life
when stealing a famous diamond
everything went horribly wrong now I
must get out of prison and set things
right for his son all right are you
ready yep yes I'm ready what's up Road
hello later I can't read your name but
hello from Bulgaria welcome to our
stream yeah I have that frequently
what's up Star gamers all right I will
switch the pip to whatever we needed to
I have a couple I really should have
made a just video game one in case oh
it's so quiet I figured they'll probably
be a lot of people wearing wait who
which one are you yeah yeah this is true
they will be wondering which one it is
each of us yeah so I guess the premise
is we are two brothers who are trying to
escape prison right look is that gonna
be actual brothers I did not look up I
might be other than
I know that we're trying to get out of
jail together I thought with your
brothers I want to be your brother I'll
double-check just two protagonists okay
we might not be brothers but the guy who
made this game feel like we're brothers
the guy who made us am made yes okay so
I I might my lines are cross in my brain
we're pretty much like brothers right
like if you're trying to get out of jail
together you know gotta have some
brotherly love that's right or die yeah
exactly but yes you can do all night
co-op for the person yeah so it's a dark
School Bus are all prison school buses
black Allen piers that is for is he
asked as this game worth buying I think
it's for you guys to determine our
reviewer gave it a 6 out of 10 with
criticisms based heavily in the writing
and story but if you like co-op games
this does seem to offer some really fun
puzzles and co-op missions to play with
friends so really depends on your your
feelings about that but I
maybe I'll get a better feeling about
the game after you watch this play
through the first hour yep we'll see
we're going in blind
so we know as much as you do right now
yes you guys might know a little bit
more if you've been doing research oh
here we go there yes so I'm on the left
no I'm on the less weight so you're
saying I guessed right Yeah right
nice all right so oh you're on the bus
I'm on the bus I'm in the yard mind your
way no no what year is this oh this is
this is weird it's like the alright I
got a I got a like a Ford oh you see the
same thing I do I can't drive I can only
walk I can't see the same thing also
easy
do you know have you ever met a guy
named Shawn Sullivan or calm Sully I am
have you ever met a guy named probably
not one of my friends that I've done
some he's done some contracting for
GameSpot before he now works for twitch
he looks just like the character I'm
playing does he have those sweet
sideburns yes you like I'll show you a
picture later okay what do you want
nothing now I'm gonna give this guy some
nice it by a straw you think I'm weak
you think I'm a [ __ ] huh
Oh real good oh I should let you finish
yours before I do I'm sure you do good
luck well so this was actually one of
the things I read in the review which
was the dialogue can be really
distracting to have but just like
because there's two sides of the screen
so you go No so I'm getting that the
general sentiment it is everybody is
real sad and scared well I don't know
that other guy said he'd mess people up
that she talked to a guy that was also
scared though yeah I talked to a dude
I'm scared and also the only reason that
guy was putting on a front like that's
probably because prison is really scary
yeah you probably don't want to have the
best day apparently sucks to be you ah
the gyetae is playing as is based off
hosting affairs brothers if I heard
correctly he was in the office the other
we playing co-op actually with our
Michael Hardy so really can check that
out yeah I didn't know I was sleeping at
the Oscars in here man that is a good
time that's really funny I had no idea
all right whoo I can sit on the bench yo
just chillin oh my god this guy just
pushed me do you think if I keep walking
into you all right you're not supposed
to go over there okay oh why are you in
such nice clothes and I'm in like why
are we clothed at all we're in prison we
should be wearing uniform uniforms okay
you're about to I was very confused as I
and I was like am I wearing this a nice
jacket Richard Prez is what's up y'all
what's up we are slowly making our way
through the beginning of when we just
got to prison yep we're gonna eventually
have to get out of prison it's a process
oh oh yeah
okay yours is more distracted oh I did
not know that there would be some side
profiling
luckily a picture picture was kind of in
the way I did not see that coming I'm so
sorry
nobody snitches out Shasha don't you
dare Oh anyone about what you just saw
the booty you saw nothing
how do I climb with lots of booties
right now or do you think there's like a
little side thing I hear oh you have to
you got the warden warden yep
I think oh I think I have to go down man
this is really any questions yeah
when are we allowed visitors in here I'm
not wait for your dialogue so weird now
you just go for I think it'll pie be
lower than my scene what's up with you
meditate okay so
good welcome to your new home I'm gonna
go on a women say they probably briefed
them about the visitors policy before at
this moment but you know I'm naked and
I'm walking that's all right are you
having an experience like Jumanji where
like you're you're not like an
out-of-body experience where you're like
a male for the first time yeah that's
basically how I am I'm like I'm naked
I'm a naked man oh oh you think maybe
ask him that's mine why are we all naked
because you're going to prison and you
know you're gonna you're gonna put on
your prison stuff it's just weird I I
mean look I can't be on what the
experience is but I'm gonna go on a whim
and say that you got to come up they
don't make you walk around Nicky like
this maybe they do I don't know anyone
have prison experience right do you have
to walk around Nicky like this I'm
writing my in my diary here while you
walk up gradually oh do you sneak it
over there there's my in the cells son
of a bee I know I should have been
looking up the cell I failed us I failed
this chat I'll change it oh my god
that's all you get an extra clothes
there was a little bit of dog earlier
yeah you know a quick little side
profile
yikes I know right um so yeah that was a
scene yeah so it seems like I want to
say you're like to my right and sell
wise yeah you're actually to my left
here in the stream room but we're
meeting for the first time I guess yes I
guess that other scene might have been
more like a freak like maybe we're there
at the end yeah I mean like a movie
where you started
if that makes sense a little closer
no oh I got to talk to someone I'm sorry
over there
Oh oh you're the pan this is Stefano
anyone had prison experience oh come on
you can't just ask someone questions
like these I can't I mean I mean where
are you are you a guy talk to this guy I
was sitting in then okay I feel like all
the NPC conversations are gonna be
really empty and have no impact on our
gameplay well his his wife just left him
I feel bad for him there's plenty of
fish out in the sea I think this is all
just like establishment scene and so but
I feel bad for this guy he's in for life
I'm gonna go with not even worth talking
to that guy or any of these guys really
but I think you have to oh man
wouldn't that be so I have to talk to
this guy probably because it's blocking
my way
oh no war here oh you're watching to
save me Sam
I like these like non descript accents
they don't seem like you might be on the
outside but this dude pays me good don't
you plan your instance it makes me
really good to give you well so I don't
know if you don't stay yeah you might
but like people in prison they are
allowed to shop it like a commissary in
prison and your family can give you
money to spend in the commissary oh yeah
so you know you get like an allowance so
you've been to prison yeah my dark past
pregame spires yeah oh yeah yeah come on
Sam help me up come on [ __ ]
ooh oh you want to dance let's dance
baby dance let's oh hey don't strike
them yeah oh man all these Oh turns out
your mash mash mash mash mash Oh
triangle circle triangle square square
square square square special square what
do I get to do something
I'm getting my cut whoops hey gamer
turns out you're the fighter Oh oops
oh come on they can make a few different
buttons no this is about the story
this isn't about quick time events don't
know what happens if you fail I'm not
gonna fail we got to get through we got
to get out of prison this is great what
you know about that no we're just
playing the game counter that okay I'm
sure it gets harder later yeah yeah yeah
what's up brother here we are your
friend
oh one two oh that guy knows martial
arts but it doesn't matter a little
little combo package oh this is Avengers
now right oh my god here let me swing
over to you your turn Oh what of course
you know you know what game is like
QuickTime events the game heavy rain
heavy rain that was like barely a game
it was like a story with like just
QuickTime events inside I destroyed that
guy stay the hell away from me okay what
no you come I thought we ever help me
any time
yeah I thought we just helped each other
out yeah be read heavy rain was good I
mean it was interesting I got the bat I
got one of the very weird endings I'm
not gonna spoil it for you guys if you
haven't played it but that game has a
plethora of strange and bizarre endings
yeah yeah okay
but I do like the story it was pretty
graphically impressive but it was it was
all just it was just QuickTime events
now I think like yeah it does look
pretty good that's a pretty good meal
that is a pretty good meal I was
actually just talking to a corrections
officer this week and I had a I was like
a friend of her friend
breakfast mmm and like he was telling me
what like people and SF get and it's not
very great it's over food yeah he's like
yeah they get like some oatmeal for
breakfast and then they get like like an
oval sized piece of like soy patty and
it's like literally this big you can see
that the corner there man that is rough
yeah because I was telling him I was
like if I'm a homeless person what did I
want to go to jail hey you know I think
that's you sometimes
me neither man you don't like me guys Oh
what do I want to do help them here or
show some force kind of weird I can't
get over it
no a mess with John Sullivan no get into
care you gotta get into oh it's not just
cause trying to shake okay here we are
oh I'm not rescuing you even though you
were real not nice to me earlier oh
really oh sweet what if he do that no I
bet you had probably oh here we go fight
number two go for it kitchen fight I
love kitchen fights oh oh that's what's
on the ground I know what a waste I
could eat all that yeah seriously
Oh punch where's my next QuickTime event
wait for it oh he's got the knives
oh the phone this wouldn't ya know they
would not make knives or to leave you
like that in prison oh yeah okay oh oh
come on away back away back away
oh yes they're on that too yeah how do
you feel about that bad the cow under to
the face alright another tray take that
you dummy
big dumb dumb jerk man for the night
yeah
b-boy maitre says it's the 70s I think
things were probably more lacks and you
know what go with yeah I probably didn't
care like the mic oh you're good oh that
was like he's going into the tank or
whatever good solitude
oh yeah he's getting a jacket he's going
yeah we I don't think we'll see him for
a while Rin Dom here yeah yeah colander
that's right hello nurse I hate those
things
Haley no they're worse things to worry
about in here not afraid of knives
afraid to need to be careful yeah
oh all right why are we getting a needle
what's that for
I don't know painkiller hopefully just
lay down a rest for a while I'm trying
to be pretty nice considering I just got
in a skirmish yeah normally in prison
that's like uh yeah they just throw you
in jail all right or like back into
yourself
definitely wait that's screwdriver to
get out that's what it is
needs more Scooby Doo chase music I'm
gonna say everything needs more Scooby
Doo chase music what's your beef with
that guy anyway but don't worry about
him this is when we bond I think yeah I
think so you do me a favor
like what there's something I need
that's the other room man it's simple
just go get me that's good I need you to
watch my back while I get it that's all
yes I'm gonna go get the screwdriver in
the other room that's how he talks
yeah I love this guy's axe is so funny
wait what you can't just walk out of
here of course I can
looks like that up in the hole I don't
have a choice all right just don't get
caught
oh do I have to sneak is this a skeleton
part yeah the diversion yeah I probably
is good cool this is good well I did
read something about how they wanted
kind of like each scene to to feel a
little bit different like you're doing
something different so you know we just
went through our QuickTime event part
now we're now I'm gonna do some right so
I I just thought oh you just called I
called the nurse that she's gonna be
distracted you're gonna hide hide hide
oh no oh you messed up dang it I hit
square I failed I failed uh Sam failed
me I know now we're both alright let's
try again yeah we had a second chance
okay
nurse alright so here hold on did you do
it alright now do it cuz I'm like I'm
hiding behind the door yeah yeah okay
yeah that makes sense
so really you screwed up yeah no
actually actually it was my fault a lot
in position yet Sam what year is this
game in I'm not sure okay so supposed to
cancel this pretty nurse hugged me okay
chat with her a little bit some water
cuz that guard is over there are you
gonna clean up a sore throat can I have
some water please
sure thanks I can't that's cool so I
kind of delay there they give you a
little timer I need to wait for that
guard to move thank you game thank you
for telling me that I love in games give
you hints you need to talk I'm not
bothering you of course not it's my job
this is good this is good this gets him
keep oh I should have talked to her
first before why the water for sure do
you think that she can so uh how did you
end up working in a prison just kind of
made sense I don't keep the conversation
going a bit pale something wrong you
look pale is something wrong yeah you're
doing everything hey you look a little
little tan no pill Vincent do something
about that guard okay that guard did you
not hear her drop the glass I dropped
the glass I don't know if I wasted that
card or not like I might we might have
wasted that situation oh yeah knock on
it okay let's go hold on
oh no now's the time right look she's
right there she's gonna know all right I
just feel like she's bent over picking
up the glass so it's not gonna get
better than this wait till she turns
around okay all right okay now she's
done you do you you just tell me when to
steal the tool Oh oh yeah I hope I
didn't know we're good we're good
cuz I have no more I have no nothing
left to do oh shoot poor man I feel bad
about it yes go to the bathroom yep yeah
I better head to the bathroom you better
kill yeah let's talk and hang out and
Seth oh I am really hungry I'm shocked
she didn't see me through the window
really hungry
could you get me some more food please
oh she's about to leave where's she
gonna go food we just served do i oh no
keep her keep her attention there that
was a tiny portion hundred percent come
on that portion couldn't feed a
hummingbird okay I'm just I'm behind the
door metal gear right there alright bye
lady she peace oh yeah
oh no problem we've nailed it she's like
she don't even know man nope I just okay
the one time she could have sought me
through this window definitely where the
garden
yeah I saw cuz you were you were
standing you were like definitely
visible to the character that's fine
hypothetically whatever we did it it's
okay I got the screwdriver you know
they've got the screwdriver screwdriver
though I love that guy's accent he
sounds like he's from New Jersey trust
me I'm not a liar right I didn't lie to
you
I'm not a criminal oh my god
we're gonna need that later screwdriver
it looks more like something I don't
know it's not a file looks like a file
something Oh me I'm just a normal
trustworthy individual yeah
you can play this online question mark
question mark question we had two
options right it was either like co-op
online or local cloth yes in her
interlinked media says this game has its
86's I wonder where if there's any
sevens in there just like hard on the
eight or the six come on TJ it's not out
yet till tomorrow or tonight at probably
nine pm she notices how long is the
campaign the campaign is about eight
hours long I didn't have that answer
sneaked compared hey I have trust issues
we have good reasons to bust out of here
but I need to get out of here too oh
yeah mute or not my problem just
offering my help here hey you know what
I don't need your help I can handle
myself
I don't know clearly infirm are you back
there man I am just saving your butt
over and over and over again
no I help you I'll save you I know I
fight crazy
I'm an ungrateful yeah I'm gonna make
you understand it you could really use
my help
like I said I can handle myself $5.00
says he saved me one more it's what
about Harvey dead oh absolutely you
serious I'm being rich at the end of
this dream I know all right oh yeah who
you been talking to
the walls are thin in here am I supposed
to believe that let's just say that you
and me have something in common we both
want him dead
that's scary again mutual interest yeah
yeah you don't know [ __ ] about me man
Nabby not
but Harvey killed someone very close to
me your schnoz with or without you
that's a distinct matter but I'm pretty
damn sure our chances would be a lot
better if we work together and you know
that I'm not sure Pasi if NAT type 3 is
a problem it could be but I haven't
tested it we haven't tested it to tell
you if that is the case not the realist
i I'm not a hundred percent sure but my
assumption is usually the way game
releases are nowadays it's like 12:00
a.m. Eastern which is like 9 p.m.
Pacific so Eric I'm hungry I had a huge
breakfast this morning - no excuse
what'd you have for breakfast I had an
egg and ham sandwich that I made on
everything bagel thanks and it was
delicious
that sounds awesome for the last like
not even last for my whole life I feel
like I don't I've never really eaten
breakfast that needs to change it's like
the most important a cup of coffee and
you're good I'm good I have my straight
out of the [ __ ] mug yeah nice a gift
from Secret Santa Mike Marty thank you
what goes down you got that yeah you got
there it's my plan whatever use that
your plan I mean it man you [ __ ] this up
I'll kill you myself
oh my god I get it I saw grass so what's
your plan he is pretty aggressive $29.99
for those ask me you know that's now I
that sort of changes my opinions about
the game
we only got through the tutorial geez
Ross I don't know yeah the the price is
I thought that this was like a $40 game
I was wrong on that thirty $29.99
look it's us again finally we're here we
are you're right this is at the end and
this is like the reflection apart
you had an idea I'll give you that I got
you out didn't I
what do you mean you got me out oh we
got out together yeah yeah sure but if
it wasn't for me you'd still be in there
don't forget I saved your ass twice I
don't know more than I even my ass part
we buy in the first did help up 40
minutes I'd save you but like a couple
times
Vincent that's true a little bit right
DK stream it's on ps4 I believe Xbox one
as well and PC origin right I'm almost
positive on that I wouldn't feel like I
looked up I'm biased biases you were
talking about breakfast they're talking
about breaking out they've been talking
about bring it out they've been talking
about bring it out yeah that's what
we're doing that's been established come
on now Xbox one PlayStation 4 windows
yep you guys don't know this on
Thursdays we I can't help but I feel
like it happens at one point in every
stream on Thursday I just have to talk
about food that's fine it's a part of
everyone's life it's true yeah okay so
we're still to prison back of the prison
yep back in time no planning still
cleaning all right I got another guy to
help us out sup Leo I'll see about that
I need to get up on that roof can you
make it happen it's gonna cost you you
know I'm good for it
I think that means he has money what do
I got
oh let me slip you a couple dots a
couple cigarettes an apple a couple a
couple of days prisoner Kruger don't see
you think again every time you say these
things it makes me feel more and more
like a man bro did you hear about that
pigeon that delivered cigarettes to
prisons yeah so pigeons are like really
smart and can be trained to do lots of
crazy some people were saying I and I
was actually just had a conversation
with another friend about a pigeon and
how like Joey not judge another person
now hurry up but apparently right here
the pigeon was rescued by like a
friend's father the father named the
pigeon all right and the pigeon totally
knows his name now that's amazing she's
like crazy right because like everyone's
general assumption is that pigeons are
pretty dumb oh my god just so fast
nature this yeah how long have you been
working up here and I get the chisel are
we supposed to tart the entire roof yeah
pretty much it's gonna take forever that
right need a distraction so we'll be up
do I need to distract yeah I think you
guys
sighing sure
alright I'll keep talking about these
prisoners we all gotta fight with
somebody
Shh no but seriously pigeons are super
smart what happened I don't know okay I
don't know where the game now
no is it there did it oh wait here it
oh it's back its back day okay
whoo I don't even know what he asked me
but ously yeah I know what happened
there sorry about that guys panic ensues
oh I could break the stick
[Music]
oh well with that noise guarding my
broom is busted ah yes well don't just
stand there get a new one
sure that was convenient where I get a
new one at I hear you're the guy who
knows how to get things around here well
depends on what you want a record player
or a way out of here a record player
obviously can you help with that no
signal screaming yeah and how much would
that cost art of the game climb that
alright so hi sir
my stick is broken
stay here Louise okay I got that card
out of there nice how did you track the
other guard though hmm
I don't know I'm still figuring that out
oh wait no maybe I can climb now I think
I think why are you over here
oh are you gonna get it well we're doing
it together teamwork makes the dream
work the gloves come back oh alright
you're going up oh look at this
yep good work Sam yep they'll never know
what are you doing nothing what's the
problem what's the problem
oh you know broom come here coming
so I get back to work ya think you can
climb I don't think wait I think you're
good yeah got the chisel get you back
down okay
time to head back you got a swab swab it
okay
I'm going down maybe I can break like
another broom hey Brooke hi what this
broom is broken too sir oh I gotta go
talk to him
time to break your broom again track
time god damn it excuse me sir
how's the wife and kids it's hot as hell
up here tell me about the weather is
sure Hina forum is making me sweat like
a pig that's because you are pig should
get some beers should get some beers
what you know some nice cold beers that
it cools down and make days go by faster
that's true great restaurant oh there
was a window there there's a window in
there I guess so I mean so far
everything's broken the chisel hold old
brothers old Wow how do they not hear
that I don't know but oh you're gonna
come back down and around here alright
time to find a way back out again
I got you I got you watch yo I'm
breaking this door for you come on come
on out bro
thank you oh hey hey just swabbing the
deck over here are you Fred oh no I got
to go to Fred this fred is swabbing the
deck here Sep Fred don't kill me with
that later okay thanks can never trust
anybody that's true I don't know why we
gave that to Fred to be so coming back
around to the pigeons story sort of just
let that hang in right I think that we
just need a pigeon to help us in this
game yeah yeah so that page I could have
picked that up for us and then even
imagine
easy easy yeah we could have had a
trained pigeon oh look you do to me in a
book real yeah it's because all the
pages are gonna be cut out and the thing
is gonna be inside I'm special sweet
write the pages cut out yeah I think so
yeah we don't even know but I imagine
that's how it fit in there's pretty
pictures I would have never taken it out
that quick right oh is this gonna be
some hot like they're gonna file itself
shank redemption stuff going on oh oh
yeah
all right tell me when they're coming
cuz I guess I am doing some Oh coming
he's coming he's coming he's coming dude
well I can't do anything about it right
now get out no you need to not yep I
can't tell that you cancelled it good
call
keep going keep going what really yeah
okay
I can't sleep do you have a book I could
read what do I look like a librarian go
to sleep cancel you know just stop
busting my balls man
reading a book all right now do it now
do it and do the thing I'm trying it was
a little nerve-racking I only got to
unscrew one of the thingies here what
I'm totally oh it's the other way not
doing a great job the pressures getting
to me yeah screw this panel here hold
that chisel in here okay oh shoot he's
coming okay we're canceling you know why
can't I like fake lay in bed or like
actin normal oh hey officer how you
doing they're doing pretty good great
mm-hmm yep I'm just not tired tonight go
to sleep I like how he told you to go to
sleep but not Billy right okay so now I
think you can go back to doing your
thing like what didn't you like try to
like fake like you're reading a book or
something yeah the other guard is
definitely gonna come again and I am
probably trying to distract him again
this is what makes this game interesting
I suppose so yeah this is the part
that's probably just like more options I
feel like so far it's been pretty like
linear yeah I'm pretty much like hey I
mean we did screw up that one time but
that's because we just weren't kind of
in sync
yeah but I feel like I think I can
finish before this guy gets here yeah
you got it squirts bear you know I'm
just gonna be real safe I hope there's
no time limit on this
oh you're chatting with them yeah yeah
I'm chatting okay you have a second yeah
visiting day when tomorrow visiting day
oh we good I know I gotta give you the
chisel tune yeah go to sleep
oh I definitely don't want pass it yet
what's up guard nah screw you that's
higher see all right hey there he goes
now we gotta do now you gotta do it yeah
oh wait oh hey guard nothing to see here
we'll see doings we're just hanging out
you know
all right here I stay near that thing
I'm gonna receive tool okay there you go
you got a hold our team all right now
I'm on the lookout is that what it is
yeah all right that guards good so we're
fighting for that guard now at this
point oh my god yeah I know right yeah
oh crap lipstick
okay my guards coming back maybe I can
engage in a conversation but you might
want to cancel out yeah you won't you
gonna cancel out no you're engaging in a
conversation distract him
what do you would I can't see the other
one though what'd you say nothing sure
go back to bed okay cancel cancel cancel
okay good well hang it out I am I'm
sleeping on I want a bed on that sorry
the other guards coming don't do
anything it I think I was coming yeah
I'm chillin chillin good
is he gonna tell you to go to sleep -
I'm acting natural look at me chillin
and myself standing here thinking in my
thoughts you're good I think canceled
canceled Oh God I didn't think you'd
Patrol back oh he's an idiot oh he's so
all right go ahead
oh my goodness hey turns out you're
pretty quick yeah just spam that the
square for sure yeah I like this yeah
anyway but no it's one coordinating yeah
I'm happy that we got to this point
because the beginning was quite slow
alright your guards coming back and I
can't distract him I would cancel now no
I would cancel now I would totally okay
you're right oh man you know why I
didn't want you to do that it was
because I was sure I'm scared okay
exactly that's why I didn't want you I
kicked a wire down there man re let's go
let's go though I gotta see if it came
back though I don't think I did it did
yeah I gotta be careful oh so wait do I
have to do that all over I really hope I
don't have to do that all right so you
have the tool also the screen is
you're asking salary sick what are you
doing up this late
where did it signal go she broke me we
can chisel
maybe I just touched the wires of my
foot again oh man
monitor is going to sleep maybe the blue
one oh my goodness let's just blame hey
everybody when in doubt blame Tay it's
definitely not my fault Carlos Medina
says somebody please somebody answer how
are you playing this question my crush
my coach mark this game comes out
tomorrow question mark explains point
explanation point explain boy i
pre-ordered it exclamation point
a lot of them we are playing this
because we got it early to review it
because we are I don't know if you new
here but this is game spot and we are
now look at those cables anymore ok I
promise I won't but we're now the
reviews games so we get them we get most
games early so ok that's how we got it
that's why we're going up this morning
I'm the one doing the lookout so I think
you got to start from square one okay so
this time be more cautious you're right
should I listen to you the first time
I'm just happy that I don't have to do
mine over and it's just yours that would
have been another 10 minutes hey it's
all your fault yeah pretty much
that's a pretty standard here my guards
coming but I think I can distract him
for a second
your guards eventually going to be on
his way to you shake hands oh I need to
cancel no he track him
exhaust rack this guy what do you want
okay now push what now yeah I'm gonna
kill how much you make an hour as a
guard more than you make being a
prisoner now oh you okay
oh yeah be pre-emptive now nice now I'm
worried Oh what I thought
turn it sorry guys preemptive huh cage I
got I feel I feel responsible to answer
the questions even if they seem silly he
might not be you know Carlos is probably
new here alright my guys come in your
guys not I'm gonna distract in but
that's only gonna last so long obviously
okay hey garden what do you want
that's what that's broke what do you
want me to do about it I want you to fix
it yes sir just gonna take a leak your
guards coming your guards coming okay
he's gonna pie walk past me to you so we
got to make sure he walks past to you
before initiating excuse me okay we
can't I can't fake going asleep which is
unfortunate what am i doing no he's
coming back he's coming back he's coming
back
okay now go go for it he's walking away
okay my goodness I love this is like the
part where you to show your ps4
controller because you just grind out
the joystick where's the action no
shooting there is shooting later I know
that there's like a scene where like one
of us is on driving the motorcycle the
other one shooting we had some action
earlier some fistfights yes we had a
knife fight in the kitchen my guard is
coming but I'll probably be able to
distract him so I think I'll be able to
get a little bit what do you you sure
yeah now go back to bed
please hide it that's enough thank God I
had me right there my heart was let's
pretend to see we gonna get out of
prison man uh Jung said I was happening
so fast you don't even know I had two
fingers like this going go to bed but it
wasn't lights out yet what whatever
Jarrod says this is a copy of prison
break the TV show I didn't watch a
prison break
okay let's hope we're smart enough that
Lee's old can we talk about the fact
that this toilet has no hole underneath
it like it's or no plumbing yeah like
what is that that's so cool we are smart
enough to pull the toilet back to fake
it at least okay well at least we
there's some type of plumbing because he
said it sinks okay so I guess do you
like go in the toilet and then all just
like drains into this the back of the
wall like what is that is there a path
farther down that way
I'm waiting for the game to give me
something prompts as it usually does I'm
pretty sure this isn't going to work
where is this nowhere
I think there was a path pass yeah I'm
gonna go down there past yeah oh yeah
and then I can do something here oh my
goodness
need your help I would love to watch
this boy yeah King KB that's fine if you
know one guy spoiled obviously don't
watch we're just in the first hour or so
yes we just started this up totally
understand if you don't worry all right
cool this is quite a break open the door
excuse me sir
which fan though this one probably the
spinning one over here yeah I'm gonna
guess it's this one the one I'm at cuz
yours has a great on it oh yeah that's
fair oh I want you to get diced up I
want to let go put down I need your help
here hey man
find a way to stop the fan I can't get
you have something on that side too he
means
to find something for you
okay I wasn't shut down it can go
through now nice I can't fit through
that come on
alright now we both need to do this the
store thing yeah okay what an easy
escape it's probably good that prison
isn't this easy to escape it's also
probably they put a lot of prisons on
island we're gonna need something bit
down there wait wasn't that a ladder
Oh bounce out then oh yeah
so why to Bria yakked says are they
brothers or does buddies they are not
brothers and I don't even know four
buddies really for some reason we're
helping each other break out of prison
oh we bonded over the mutual hate
another Cromartie we do that Harvey - it
sounds easy enough I should be listening
problem is they don't allow him make
something you think we can sneak in
somehow yeah but we're gonna need to get
a hold of a laundry cart the cart one of
us has to hide in it know what the guard
will inspect it and then bring it to the
bathroom
what do you mean they're gonna inspect
it don't worry about it they don't look
too
as long as we're covered in sin sheets
you should be fine okay so we fast
forward to present day now we're in the
laundry room yes
all right we can't get laundry part
okay here we go guys if you're looking
for a real challenge get to prison in
real life and then try to escape yeah
okay I'll tell you how that goes
this man is dancin first time I've seen
someone smiling here
yeah it's because I'll be a free man
this week I'm happy for him it is okay
definitely can't I think we got to do
something to get that girl got any
family on the outside nope I'm just
gonna get drunk and hit up the strip
clubs Wow Wow can't do that for the rest
of your life why not there are plenty of
strip clubs out there all right then you
this is so weird you imagine a man that
talks like that I am excited to go to
the strip clubs
hot-diggity-dog man he's been in prison
a long time this is true oh maybe you
forgot to socialize oh I'm concentrating
here what do you want all right I won't
bother you then well that ship has
sailed hasn't it what do you want oh man
where did the sheets oh uh when you're
done here where do all these sheets go
hello fine no go farther that guy
instead he's keep breaking down all the
time what's the problem with them I
don't know man they just keep breaking
down pieces [ __ ] cancel a conversation I
got real bored feel like I wanted to
open that door past the guard but I feel
like as a mistake probably too soon
all right holding sheets yeah I just put
something to wash shirts clean by now
yeah see that what everybody made that
washer nice where I put these dry work
these two germs germs leads to disease
disease leads to death I care about well
I put these I have them just carry these
sheets around yeah yeah I just gotta get
rid of this dirt you can couch co-op
train local germs leads to disease and
disease leads to death you're definitely
not okay you definitely not okay on the
ground how dare I
I've no idea oh oh okay maybe if you're
holding a sheets you can go to the door
oh you think so
maybe alright good luck to you the door
has passed to this guard over here not
that nope I got I got turn down this
door where I'm at I try to talk to him
why you made me try to thank you I can't
talk now why am i holding these sheets
Yolo that's from there go on okay maybe
not so good don't know what to do these
sheets come on I want to ask you
something nope not now go away I feel
like we got to get that guy out of here
whoa what are you doing inmate well go
away from there go on okay
I'm so sad right now like what am I
supposed to do these sheets well there
is one that's open this one right here
no but these were clean are they're
clean the clean and they're folded we
try going into this other room right now
oh hey what's up bro well you got going
on over here
hey oh this is a laundry cart guy I
needed a laundry cart oh thank you have
your number please what do you need that
for
it's rules and regulations nothing I can
do about it it's the cart man I need
your name and number give him your name
a commission I'm not on the list
what's your name again Leo close it's
not here but yeah you know last mail
yeah Wow let's get that card that guy
doesn't matter we're gonna get that cart
are you gonna get in this car or am I
getting in the car girl pushy
oh we got fill out all the sheets here
you go whoo could you put that you have
some over here there and over here
though okay sweet
we're getting real efficient here max
efficiency good let's go
no we need more sheets I know you're my
way I'm trying to this card isn't that
easy to maneuver all right can't jump in
now better find another spot okay hold
on let me get more sheets okay cuz
there's not enough sheets in there would
be enough hidin okay a little bit just
in case one you know yeah just in case
you never know really oh yeah do you do
you it's gonna make sure okay now let's
get in there let's just go go back in
this room and then I'll get in which
room oh you wanna like real sly yeah
like nothing happened here like a magic
trick
yes go in there oh you okay I like this
all right the number was punch there are
no sheets in there I don't think there's
any sheets in here I think I wouldn't
you nn8 reset it yeah yeah yeah I'm not
even joking I don't know about it we'll
find out all right
I can't jog
Oh see your cheats hiding yeah yeah yeah
do that
do that thing hello I can't hello can i
push this cart
Vincent Cass person says how long is
this game it is 8 hours ok see what we
have here washi all right looks go what
an idiot a lot of sheets it out of the
way Oh what Oh cuz you got to go to the
other room
ok got it ok time to get rid of that
guard now yeah I'll get rid of this
guard good luck to you I'm gonna have a
chat with him even though he's denied me
multiple times what are you doing get
the hell back to work sure broken
there's a problem with that washing
machine oh yeah what's the problem I
don't know it's broken
it doesn't look broken stop lying
get back to work
aha okay I'm out of there I'm about to
break this machine though think for some
reason I have more sheets there I put
these down get rid of those I guess I
need Leo in here to help me with this
okay
wait hold on I'm working on it I'm
breaking no jeans you didn't believe me
I had to make you believe me I'm on my
way
cuz that other guard never saw oh it's
locked can you let me in yes I got put
these sheets down okay cool I see you
sneaking shoot that guards looking you
don't see nothing do you see him though
music over there what did you need help
what the door in here me there's earth
now we need to put the sheets into it Oh
where's the way to I need to grab I need
some sheets please that's awkward
it was an awkward handing of sheets Oh I
need some more sheets okay we had a
ma'am
nothing but sheets here what happens
when you're out don't know yet didn't
get that far is there both of our first
times playing the game oh my god any
more sheets oh yeah I do
I put them in here
hilarious
and I'm pretty I'm pretty strong here
miss Rocklin a lot now I get out
all right please cutscene yeah we don't
even have to sneak out oh my god is it
for us yeah you only need one copy and
you and your friend can play together
yes
oh look we're back here we didn't have
to do any of the sneaking all right that
should do it
yeah let's hope so I thought I was gonna
tell you to go first pushes me off okay
see ya let you go first yeah smart I'll
catch you don't worry right here
catch me baby hold me okay
oh I think we're both gonna have to do
this part
mmm-hmm we we don't skip arms oh no we
don't skip arm day only like this only
leg day two little twigs on the bottom
yep very much around
really it's pitch black we need a light
oh yeah finally you got to find a way
sir taco says that's pretty sick for 15
bucks each you can have a cool game for
the weekend that's true it is a fun
weekend game to play with friends
I can't I also my supposed to do I'm
trying man
oh crap flashlight convenient place to
just randomly have a flashlight aw
shucks it okay oh look it's a little
slide there hi there I just slipped down
a bit to the left
what who's all dark that's why we needed
some light Leo smartass huh
I'm concerned you think lighting up a
dark area smart can you flash the light
towards me yeah there's something here
that I think I need you to shine it for
me I'm heading that way I don't think I
think I have to do it from on top though
okay yeah
noise heading up heading up to your
right turn your right
why can't I get no no so if you go back
you can kind of see me off to your left
yep yeah shine there okay Elio yep
because I couldn't spin that in the dark
yeah yeah like I had to see it you had
to see it to know I mean it's true thank
you man oh I think you need on this one
too okay because again I cannot turn
this wheel without ya if you cannot see
it you do not believe it
I'll see you there in a second maybe
just stay there I think can open this
door or I gotta take a flashlight from
you behind you
take it thank you all right I'm gonna go
down this hallway probably let you in on
that other side yeah I know it's locked
don't worry your boys right here stay
there I'm unlocking the [ __ ] or maybe or
not yes don't worry I'm a strong man yep
take a rock all the technology we've
developed and all it takes is rocks to
destroy it
yeah man rock life I'm guessing this
doesn't work get over here
let's push this up what I'm gonna bust
the door up we're bustin it up it up
three two one bust it up maybe it's you
that same time there yeah yeah we did it
probably is I can't see oh god okay
oh did we have to go the other way
probably well then I guess I should have
followed the side and again are you
running cool is this net what are there
no prompts I heard a rat definitely
heard a rat let's go towards the light
maybe wait here yeah this is a this is
the gate there's not we can't go that
way
yeah no there was also a gotta find a
prawns
he may maybe no no the only thing that I
didn't go check was over here somewhere
all right let's go which I don't think
is anything though I don't know why you
would open that door otherwise yep I've
got to go back the other way
derp derp
I guess a mini-map would not make sense
in this game I mean we're supposed to
figure this is like a new puzzle right
yeah there's nothing you can pick up
right like there hasn't been any like
icon or anything like that
nope okay that glass
oh wait what about here
okay hold on do you see no no this is a
new path okay great
I think oh yeah yeah did it
we are we out no there's no way we're
out yet that's the whole game is getting
out so well no there's stuff definitely
stuff after it's Jewett man what I've
seen from the trailer and nothing to
climb on either alright back to the
prison we're gonna wall climb we're
gonna press each other yep yep I need to
bad yep I knew that was gonna jump in oh
yeah
time to get buff are you kidding me no
no push against my back we're gonna have
to oh I missed so it has to be in the
middle it'll be much quicker
oh god okay in the middle got it good
good job on here we weren't even that
high yeah okay
oh I missed it I miss Grove you go this
is like you go again I missed it
you gotta go again this is like shooting
free throws and then you know I think
yeah wait to look at me okay
I missed
you go yep working on it wait did that
not you do okay
Daniel we're gonna die are we
like how there's a guard like casually
walking there oops
oops
oh my get the hang of it
yep Oh what oh you go you all right you
do it twice now now we're good you can
go sorry I did it I did automatically
being like oh he did it man this is this
is a long trek I know everybody watching
right now is like just get it right man
don't watch it do it
just just gotta fight just
[Music]
guys this is the game that we are
playing I miss the line
he's like those old basketball games at
the free-throw line
like the field goal oh man we're almost
out I can see it I think I believe in us
and we are strong though this is
coordination this part went on for much
longer than I thought it was gonna how I
seize on speed run this right whoo I
almost hit it thinking you got it but
good yeah my goodness speed run it
that's CJ this game would be difficult
with all the little weird quick time
events and write something like that are
you [ __ ] serious a wrench would be
nice there's only one place you can get
that are you serious after all that
climbing with a damn it Wow go wait damn
right yeah how funny if we had to do
that again no childhood tricks up your
sleeve
afraid not [ __ ]
ready to do it again I'm just kidding
they're probably gonna fast-travel us
there cuz there's no way they didn't
make us go through that again if the
game really wanted to be challenging I
guess they would but it wouldn't be
really challenging or just be infuriated
us do that again just like got a nice
little troll alright so that takes us to
an hour officially of this game what do
you want to do you want to do you want
to steal this wrench or you want to call
it oh boy what are you it what do you
what do you guys you guys want to see us
continue onward I'm guessing they're
gonna want us it's we're stealing the
room we're stealing the Randall shilling
the wrench we are stealing the wrench
we're stealing Johnny Epson okay we're
doing it
so smuggle the wrench to your cell you
know I would do for some cheese's right
now what would you do
steel wrench still runs from Jesus all
day man this thing spins fast I'm just
making a wooden leg here there's a
carpentry right now yep all right yeah a
carpenter sorry you we're gonna get into
the furniture business together yeah
that is our life after prison we're
gonna overthrow a Restoration Hardware
we're killing what's-his-name and then
we're gonna start a new harmony yeah
we're gonna kill Harvey and then we're
gonna start something called Restoration
Hardware - okay but a restoration
however better
here I seriously just hold this the
whole time I am gonna cancel nice I
think yeah you can hit okay you know as
as calming as that was I'm good I didn't
realize that wow you're you're making
stuff yes what do you need what do you
need a hammer it's pretty hard to get
any work done without got a hammer then
you shouldn't have a hammer I can't oh
you have because I can't find it here
[ __ ] what yeah what a bunch of what -
fun of bees man our nation stage
oh there's the wrench better keep like a
little better way nice what is happening
all right well girl basser yes thank you
wicked music box I'm just like randomly
a song song would ya yeah making a lamp
it looks like is it ever gonna is it
ever gonna break what do you want
I need your hammer what do I want you
may even get a hammer no I'm gonna knock
this guy out probably for the hammer
quick question for you I just have a
quick question for you what day is it
no no date I need to know the date [ __ ]
if I know man
she lose track of that [ __ ] here oh I
thought I was totally gonna knock that
guy out for it see I got the wrench
ok let's fight for it I wish okay you
have the wrench no I can't he this guy's
protective about his reg hey what do you
want what do I want
yeah what do you want
turn that out if I want you to turn down
that out of Toulouse what attitude I
don't have an attitude
see there you go get come on man I'm
just trying to do my job here that
didn't work
oh my do you think I'm gonna be smashing
this like the same you were dang hey
it's just a place to get tools just
hammering watch it he's saying the same
thing he said this hard you know just
walking through the center here - hey
guard looks like this some guard that
bit oh hey remember that little spot
that's how we're gonna smuggle it out
for sure that little event thing can't
figure this I'm gonna talk to this man
now maybe I'll get the wrench don't I
recognize you from somewhere
I don't know I'll go back to making a
challenge to work at the log yeah sure I
got transferred probably Oh borrow that
tool yeah yeah borrow that I borrow that
tool this one
no why not because the guards would go
crazy if I gave you this tool man you
gonna check out your own tools over
there okay
I'll do that Oh or do you check out the
tools from over here but I already try
it didn't work and this guy's blocking
me yeah I need to get my hammer oh my
god this is so frustrating maybe maybe I
could talk to him now hey man listen you
know what happens if I don't get this
done on time ooh he's upset I bet you
don't
why can't you listen you know what
happens I took the wrench god is sweet
okay so we just had to distract him the
whole time wow that was all right I
wasn't that worked out it's so annoying
that he's got a slide under there but
let me get to the other side real quick
did that work yeah yep on my way
pass it along yep nailed it to myself
maybe something
in the so I'm down the stairs yeah oh
snap I might need you here on my way
cool feel like you might need to do some
distracting in front of us or wait
what's this
Oh am i passing it to you again yeah all
right I'll pass it to you
we're already ahead of the game game
game I didn't think that I didn't think
that it was as easy as just distracting
the guy getting the wrench that way I
know that was something I that was so
funny that we sat for like good good 30
seconds though I'll take I'll take the
I'll take the blame for that one plate a
that's alright hashtag win - the
struggle of this stream so far you know
yep easy hey yeah listen man it's two of
us now oh my goodness we're getting
slayed in the tavern ourselves like this
way from what Oh
hey officers hey boys there's a problem
what is it let me show you come on
yeah sure you got it you go you go
because yeah these guys leave me yeah
just get back to the cell going on
downstairs you need to check it out I
don't want to fight him let's go all
right step aside Wow
they believed me let's go I love it
just an honest man doing some honest
things shakedown up against the bars in
me oh shoot
I'm coming did you hear me I said up
against the bars this is not good don't
worry about nope
oh you hit it though right
yeah it's like in my body oh yeah three
places later it's the toilet of course
it's the toilets always spoil it when is
it not the toilet I don't know it's been
the go-to right this entire time
what's up line monkey good job thank you
thank you my favorite part of this whole
stream so far was me shaving the wood
for like 30 seconds and then realized
what was happening yeah my table leg or
whatever chair alright looks like we
stole the wrench pretty good job there
good job yeah I wonder if they'll
fast-track us to the top now so I don't
have to do that whole thing all over
again
Oh what's up baby you're not allowed to
do that really no again this is from the
actual knowledge right yeah you know
I'll just touch your visitors like that
I'm not even handcuffed I got a plan to
get out of here why would you tell her
that what can I do
don't worry pick us up yeah as if this
whole thing hasn't been recording isn't
recorded Vincent Vincent right there are
you sure I mean we both thought we could
trust Harvey this guy wants to take him
down
I do what man I guess nose is quite
large I don't know yet I don't know but
I'll find out okay so how's Alex well
it's been six months he misses his
father oh this is sad you got a son
these are nonsense to put yourself in
jail what can I do I need your help
oh this is true listen it's fine he
still thinks you're in Italy helping
your uncle oh oh my goodness it's hard
tomorrow don't worry about that you
won't find us are you sure yeah I got us
a new place we should be safe for now
this is so funny to me I just I always
think the Staten Island New Jersey the
type of guy sucks oh wait what oh you
wanna make a phone call all you want to
go back to your cell that's sad
I'd like to make a phone call sir let's
go the SADS wife don't she pray yeah
Carol why aren't you here because I'm at
home expecting our baby all that sad
we've talked about this no you've talked
about this I didn't have a say at all
you're in prison I'm gonna be out soon
listen to yourself Vincent this isn't
who you are
is this how you want your future child
to remember you no but I need to take
care of the Harvey situation if you
escape prison if you like there you're
never gonna have a free life like if you
like okay I'm sorry no it's okay it's
just gonna get yourself killed
please you know I have to do this it's
like the worst idea ever
Oh Vincent yeah if I was her I'd be
pissed too yeah oh I'd be like you want
revenge more than yeah your child that's
coming into the world yeah
that is messed up welcome to a
criminal's mine this is true
oh we had the lunch we had the cafeteria
you got an apple you got what looks like
meatloaf maybe some spinach I think
you're hungry also no all right tonight
your Budweiser
there's no one coming I did that window
that was probably the most heartfelt
like part of the story so far I feel
like that could have come a little
sooner to give the background of their
characters I'm halfway tempted to break
out of do you want to break up Susan
what do you want to call it a stream or
no no we could yeah we just got to this
point
so let's I'll see it through all right
so so we're trying to get out unless
they they should somehow shaft us again
yeah let's let's see this through yeah
we got the wrench we got here let's just
try to get out we might as well 100%
agree
yeah yeah I feel bad for Vincent
you got it worse than that direction
it's sad thank God we do not have to do
that again that was gonna I was gonna
there's no it ain't happening
all right you want me to hand it over
here you go oh wait
all right now I got to do this one yep
and then when you hands it over I can't
drop it so I probably have to grab it
before I go oh never mind
no you win that would have been that
would have been a good thing though it's
like a fail state right like where I you
you have to know I have to grab it
before you let go that would have been
good I got to keep tapping square or
something
old r2 and the Yahtzee
all right I can't believe I'm out of
this [ __ ] soon it's not over until
the fat lady sings oh she's gonna say
trust well she calls sure she won't say
trust me
yes palette are we supposed to jump over
something
I think we used to climb up that man
probably so you didn't feel the
vibration but I was struggling to pull
that off he's like yeah just like that
oh you don't get the okay I was gonna
say too good to follow uh we have a lot
of new viewers I think right now so
we're just gonna like say hi to
everybody and let them know that we
stream games every day at this time so
if you like to watch games yeah we got
some actually tomorrow we'll start a
little bit earlier than normal 10:00
a.m. we got a cool one coming not sure
if I can say what it is yet but you
should come back tomorrow 10:00 a.m.
this it was Standard Time check out it
kind of another early look at another
game nice it's always great when we get
split games early yeah oh wait the other
way this way
oh man holy English crack these guys
where can we just sneak by
Yolo yeah you can just walk by
think I need your help with this door is
my guess oh you're the smart one out
yeah
oh we're timing with the thunders okay
this okay ready good nice yeah very good
by far our best yeah that was our that
was definitely our best go up there
that's our so far away oh man there's a
guard right there it's here are we
taking these guys down shoot okay
we are supposed to take that guy down
great wish me luck
I sleep sleep I drag his body
okay we're just gonna leave his body I
guess it
there's the warden look it's like the
first part of the where we were earlier
guitar yeah this is the I gotta lift you
up come on over here
alright you're going up wait do I need
to help you up
I think so
if teamwork teamwork dan you're so
strong one hand I am strong one hand no
problem
you go first all right
here we go
oh I know probably well what else was
like an unusually the smarter of the two
of us I'm the one that acts irrationally
this is true what do you got in here
wooden you got anything what are we
looking for again I don't know why I was
anaglyphic ocean I think I go through
the Warriors office right yeah I just
climbed through there even though
okay well then no other door follow it
oh hey you see me sneaking
the first two hours later up there's a
guard event we're good taking the
elevator down do we go up or down [ __ ]
goodness you can quickly check quickly
check up even though nope back down it
down it is does see that Carson show
last night there there she guards sweet
[Music]
so there's a point over there do you see
it
can we do a double-take down probably
did you structure bring it now are we
supposed to go together maybe let's go
I'm just gonna run no fear even though I
think this is the wrong way definitely
is
oh hi guys you see nothing oh wait here
it's over here this window that's your
power watch out for the spot so yeah
right to the right of the door like you
see that window no go through that
doorway and then right to your right
there's a window yep got it okay thank
you thank you
yep so weird they didn't see us and now
we get to the tower Pali without Kings
quickly the white oh my god I feel so
stupid
ah okay no hope we were right there okay
so basically yeah now I would've got
caught - I just BAM square okay all
right now I've been able ride all right
I'm gonna wait for it to like pass real
quick I bet you Oh
now yeah we're good I'm gonna go
downstairs as well and hide behind this
thing [ __ ]
oh no need to spam it I should have
hidden it's okay well you should go one
step ahead of me and then I'll just go
into your place like after the way yeah
so I'm gonna wait because it's gonna put
pan over to the right here yes we are
playing away out on PlayStation 4 on a
pro it's that matter that are there
though all the way down okay you can
hide near the stairs right now I'm gonna
wait until this goes past
oh please spam that square [ __ ] whoa
avoid the searchlight alright I don't
know where I guess forward after this
yes I can't see
yeah you should be able to creep up to
the next slide it's like there's
multiple angles of doing this because
I'm on the top right now
what's this game about - there's two of
us we both mutually hate one guy we
found out that in Sam's case Vincent's
case it's because he killed his brother
I'm gonna try to go check this guy out
and then you won't have to worry about
the searchlight potentially sweet I
don't know if that's the case but we'll
find out there's only one guy so I'd
assume taking this guy go too sweet
all right I think you should be good
because I took out the guy well coming
up coming up this game is not for you to
play is $29.99 we gotta find something
to slide down the wires with oh here you
go hangers of course
grab a hanger all right and then we're
gonna make a dramatic why are there that
I love there's a random coat rack I
don't know it's just all ready to make
this exit why is there no prompt for me
right now
I got you nice okay maybe we're not
gonna press ooh
this is like Captain America moment yes
oh I'm tap and squirt find it
I can only hold on for so long I'm not
yeah I'm coming I'm coming I'm tapping
the shizzle out of square right now
save me Erik they're shooting at us -
I'm pretty sure we're getting shot oh I
thought that was the sound of the wire
snapping but yeah it is Square it yeah
Oh tap that square
[Music]
okay multipass that's kind of cool yeah
we should probably take the same one we
nee a flashlight yeah should have kept
all those tools with us does online
co-op require PS plus uh that one I'm
not sure about actually that is a good
question yeah we're playing locals did
we just make it out I think so Wow bad
we got it yeah good job Eric good job
awesome this cutscene and then here we
are again hey I've been meaning to ask
you something what's that back in the
prison when we climbed that shaft you
know the back to back thing yeah what
about it did you really do that when you
were a kid know what it's not in a comic
book once when I was a kid
tell me you're joking no I'm just glad
it worked oh my god oh my god [ __ ]
believe you talked me into it
me neither yeah pretty much
nice okay like you guys finally found a
way out
yes Ben dang it yeah I'm just gonna let
the cuts in play yeah yeah okay all
right we got out of prison
more or less so I'm just gonna yeah yeah
that was a good stream we made it we
made it we made it out of prison well
sort of I mean we still have that whole
part where we're probably going to get
through the woods then we're gonna go
kill Harvey yeah got a family you know
my wife's gonna have a baby so I'm kind
of worried about that I'm gonna finally
have to tell my kid I wasn't in Italy
whatever you're what were your
afterthoughts so far the game I thought
was pretty cool I I think that I would
have liked there to be like a few more
options in terms of like you know when
you're in the prison and like we were
distracting or like faking like we were
weren't tired it would have been nice to
like be able to sit at my desk or like
lay in the bed just relax yeah but I
think that it's it's kind of cool that
each like area that we had to go through
required us to kind of do different
things and it does require you to kind
of work together yes if anything my
biggest gripe was I wish there were more
situations where we had to be clever
together to like solve puzzles yeah and
if those puzzles were a little less like
quick tiny and a little bit more like
actual problem solving I thought that
would have would have been cool but yeah
for what it is it is interesting and it
was a it's a unique way to tell a story
and and also have co-op yeah get some
couch co-op games again especially since
it's kind of like a dying breed in a way
yeah so once upon a time all multiplayer
games were couch co-op games yep it's
funny to think about anyway guys thanks
for tuning in and watching us play the
beginning this was only the beginning of
the game the playtime is I believe eight
hours long we just went through the
first hour and a half where we got
through the prison it probably probably
took longer doing that then it would
play through there's probably a you know
at least 7:00 a.m. hours a game play
after that um but yeah so if you guys
are interested in a way out yeah you can
definitely check out our review and
we're gonna have lots of other stuff
about the game coming out soon and you
can see us back here again every day at
11 a.m. we're gonna be playing a
surprise tomorrow you can't tell anybody
what's happening yet I don't think I can
I'm just doing that as a just in case
not really just like building your
building the height I wish I could say
that secrets building hype yeah so but
it'll start earlier tomorrow it'll be
10:00 a.m. so stay tuned for that and if
you guys want to see me again I'll be
here next Thursday alright guys I hope
you have a wonderful day awesome and
we'll see you later thanks who's bye
[Music]